what is going on everybody and welcome
to a new tutorial series this tutorial
series is with the Raspberry Pi which is
a credit card-sized it's very thick
credit card but a credit card size many
computers so what this can do is
basically anything the computer can do
for you but obviously has two things
going for it one is the size of course
and two is the readily accessible GPIO
pins which we can use to do all kinds of
things like control other robotics types
of stuff turn on and off lights move
servos we can also just take in sensor
data all kinds of stuff that we can do
with that and that's what makes this
device super powerful it also just
doesn't take that much electricity and
obviously just due to its size you can
stuff it in all kinds of cool places so
that's the Raspberry Pi now the first
thing it's kind of a weird situation
where when you first get the Raspberry
Pi the question on your mind is like
what do I even do with this as if
there's nothing you can even think of to
do with it and then as time goes on it's
actually a paralyzing lee large number
of things you can do with the Raspberry
Pi so for me I've done a whole bunch of
stuff I've put a computer in my car I've
done robotics stuff i plus turd them
together you can even actually see the
cluster in the back there that's a bunch
of raspberry PI's system I've got a ton
of these things I've used them for
cameras like security cameras around the
house and I've used them just for simple
kind of just headless machines that just
do operations for me that I want to be
like always running because here's the
thing you can you know obviously you can
compute the cloud but you can also
compute locally and the only thing that
stops local computer computing normally
and the reason why I use the cloud is
when you have things like a power outage
or something like that whereas a
Raspberry Pi you can run it on backup
power where like a computer on the most
backup power will last maybe five
minutes maybe usually more like ten to
thirty seconds whereas a Raspberry Pi
can actually last about thirty minutes
or so on backup power so anyway it just
draws such a small amount of power so
anyways that's the Raspberry Pi that's
some stuff that you can do with it let's
talk about the Raspberry Pi itself and
then some of the things that you're
going to need
or this tutorial series so what we have
here this is Raspberry Pi model B
especially a Raspberry Pi 2 model B so
and actually know this is actually this
one's a 3 I think this is the latest
version yeah this is actually a 3 most
of what I have are actually twos but
this is the latest one this will
probably be the latest model for a while
I think they came out and said that
they're not really thinking of making
another one yet so anyway this should be
it for a while but you can have any of
the different versions of the model B
the only things that change sometimes
some of the peripheral stuff changes but
the most important thing is that these
GPIO pins and GPIO stands for general
purpose input output these GPIO pins the
order they might add more like down the
line although they are running up space
they do not change in the order or the
ID so they're always going to be the
exact same idea except for the bottom
ones might be new and but the other
model bees don't have I don't think I
have a really old Raspberry Pi model B
that doesn't have as many pins this one
has 40 it's also got like one gig of ram
it's got this one has a quad-core
processor most of them just have like a
single ARM processor but yeah so that's
the Raspberry Pi now let's talk about
some of the additional things that
you're going to need so I'm just going
to move this over so the main thing that
we're going to need
additionally will be a breadboard so a
breadboard is just a really quick way to
kind of test and develop things with
circuits so we're going to be using that
with the GPIO pins so try to get one of
those although really the essentials for
the Raspberry Pi I mean just getting it
setting it up you're just going to need
the Raspberry Pi obviously itself you're
going to need at least like a 1 amp or
1000 milliamp power supply this is like
a cell phone charger it's a micro USB so
the actual power is this right here so
that's your actual power supply to the
Raspberry Pi you actually can supply
also supply power via the GPIO pins as
well but we're not really going to
with that for now so the Raspberry Pi
power supply and then an SD card
generally it's going to be a micro SD
this is a regular SD card but this is
actually an adapter so the micro SD card
goes inside it so this one is and I'm
not even a hundred Prime pretty sure you
can use a 128 gigabyte micro SD card but
I'm not a hundred percent certain but I
don't see why not but some older of it
maybe the older pods wouldn't let you
anyway regardless yet so you'll want a
micro SD card this one is 128 I'm not
actually going to be using it I just
grabbed one that was around but at least
eight gigabytes but if you ask me really
sixteen gigabytes is what you should use
or 16 or larger but yeah so make sure
you have a micro SD card or a full SD
card it depends on which Raspberry Pi
you have the later versions the SD card
goes in this right here and that's
obviously only going to accept a micro
SD card that's not going to accept the
full one but the older Raspberry Pi
model bees actually want a full sized SD
card okay so for the Raspberry Pi
basically you just need those things
you're also going to need like a
keyboard and mouse and a monitor and
these those three things you'll only
need temporarily you're not always going
to need those things so you can just
borrow them from a computer around your
house now let's talk about some of the
things we're going to need later in the
series so initially you just need the PI
power supply and micro SD card but then
later we're going to be getting into the
GPIO pins which is really the value of
the Raspberry Pi so you probably should
just go ahead and buy the other things
that we're going to be using so like I
said before the red board will talk more
about how a breadboard works
they might look somewhat different from
this one but generally they're going to
look like this rather they've got a row
here a row here actually officially this
would be more like a column I suppose
anyway something there's something there
and then a bunch of them kind of middle
separated usually but not always and
these will be separated as well so
anyways give a breadboard other than
that we're also going to need quite a
few other things so for example this
these are jumper wires
and these are and try to stay out of my
light there so you can see but these are
male to female or female male jumper
wires you really can't see the pin one
of them has a pin the other one is like
that's the male part and then so for
example this is your male this is your
female and so the male line goes with a
female end so get about at least 10 of
them but usually you can just buy like a
kid or something that has like a hundred
of these things and while you're at it
you could also just get one that has
female to female female to male male the
male just get a bunch of them for this
tutorial series at least as far out as
I've kind of planned um you'll only need
the male the female because basically
the male end goes in the breadboard the
female end goes onto the GPIO pins
themselves and you're good to go so get
about ten of those next we need we're
going to use in LED lights so in this
series we're going to use three we're
going to use a green yellow and red you
don't have to use those colors you can
get different ones it doesn't really
matter but get some LED lights you
should probably get more than three
because not always do they work and
they're just a varying quality they're
like a super cheap mass-produced product
that doesn't always meet standards next
we're going to need about ish six
resistors kind of like the male to
female jumper wires though you probably
should just get a kit of varying sizes
because you're going to need resistors
fairly frequently for this tutorial
series basically you could get by with
six 1k ohm resistors basically what we
absolutely need you're going to need at
least one 1 K 1 2 K and then 3 somewhere
between 300 and 1k ohm resistance the
reason why we need those is just either
for the sensor we're going to use a
distance sensor or the LED bulbs
themselves because they like to draw
more power than the Raspberry Pi wants
to take so those are your resistors let
me think here finally we've got the
distance sensor this is officially the
hcso the SRO for flip it around you can
actually read it on there
noted there break and stuff anyway
the HTS ro4 you're only going to need
one of those but I would recommend you
just go ahead and get at least two
because generally the thing that you're
going to use this distance sensor for is
for like a robotic car so it's useful to
have one in the front one in the rear
we're not going to do that in this
series but as we get further on I'm
going to link to a series that I've
already done that uses that so it could
be wise to go ahead and just get two of
those other than that you should be good
to go
one last thing though just because
sometimes computers come and they don't
have SD slots at least my computer
doesn't if you custom build you probably
didn't get an SD card reader because why
anyway you can buy these like little USB
ones so this is just like a USB SD card
reader and you can actually stick the SD
cards in there and then plug it in so if
you don't have an SD card reader you'll
probably want to get one of these
because it's super handy to have around
if you don't have an SD card reader but
seems like the most consumer bought
computers still nowadays do come with SD
cards but just be careful also I forgot
to mention that will also be briefly
using the Raspberry Pi camera module
it's not absolutely essential for this
series that you have it but if you want
you can get it also we use it in a lot
of the other projects that I've already
done on the on YouTube and also on
Python programming that net so if you
want to follow along with that you can
get it it's just really like the easiest
sensor to use with the Raspberry Pi just
because it's got its own special port
and everything's kind of already set up
for you anyway just want to throw them
in there cuz I forgot to mention it on
the original recording so anyway that's
that that's the introduction to the
Raspberry Pi all the parts that you're
going to need and all that and now we're
going to go ahead and do is run through
the actual setup of the Raspberry Pi on
your on your computer and then also the
SD card for your Raspberry Pi